Остання модель Мерседеса взагалі не схожа на ту, що йде
в тренді екологічних авто, а швидше навпаки - підкреслює,
що концерн робить ставку на потужні дизельні двигуни.
Двотонний пікап незабаром потрапить на європейські вулиці.
Якщо йому дозволять.
Німецькі активісти через суд вимагають заборонити машини
з дизельним двигуном у Штутґарті - серці
німецької автопромисловості. Міське повітря тут забруднене.
Екологи стверджують, що вміст оксиду азоту
у повітрі перевищив усі норми
саме через любов німців до дизельних автівок.
Активісти подали позов до суду з обвинуваченнями на адресу
земельного уряду Баден-Вюрттембергу.
Ми не просто хочемо заборонити старі дизелі одного дня.
Ми хочемо, щоб всі дизелі, які не відповідають останнім стандартам викидів,
були заборонені протягом всього року.
Це єдиний шлях, який дозволить Штутгарту
з січня наступного року повернутися до стандартів
якості повітря в ЄС.
Це буде удар для автомобільної промисловості.
Майже половина всіх авто, які продають у Німеччині -  дизельні.
Даймлер вже оголосив, що безкоштовно відкликає
три мільйони автомобілів в Європі
для оновлення двигунів на більш екологічні.
Ауді та BMW також планують еко-модифікації
своїх двигунів.
Ми категорично проти такої заборони. Існують кращі шляхи
вирішити проблему якості міського повітря.
Дуже важливо регулювати потік транспорту.
Що він регулюється, тим нижче рівень оксиду азоту в повітрі.
Поки що політики не поспішають втручатися в цю суперечку.
Зрештою, автомобільна промисловість -
життєво важлива для німецької економіки.
Від неї залежить понад 800 000 робочих місць.